hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in islam net from norway are
establishing a masjid a tawa center
establishing a masjid to convey the
message of islam is one of the best
deeds a muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in norway you know this and
i know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
allah azzawajal will give you even more
[Music]
before we start this video
um i think many of you will be aware of
the fact that in pakistan now there are
severe floods
and as the muslim community it's really
incumbent and worship upon us
to step in you know pakistan is one of
the biggest muslim countries mightiest
muslim countries and a seventh of the
population of pakistan is affected by
these severe floods one thousand one
hundred people have already been uh have
already died in these floods so i will
say please
click on the link below and help the
individuals and the people in pakistan
the reason why i'm making this video is
because actually it's come to my
attention after the fact after i've
recorded a video with ali last week
it came to my attention that there was
one
incredibly disturbing and alarming thing
that i heard
which
i think maybe if you if you listen to it
as well coming from a muslim perspective
we'll agree is totally outrageous if
understood in the way that it's stated
let's see what's said if a woman stepped
out on her marriage
the vicious poisonous let's throw her
out and get up
he could spit on camera you know but in
a man's position as long as we get a
paper from the mosque and we cover it up
it's
she states if a woman stepped out of her
marriage
now
this
phrase stepped out of her marriage i'll
be honest with you
i thought she meant a divorce and still
maintain that she might have meant that
if a woman tried to try to seek a
divorce would try to go for a hola or
something like that
then xyz and then she goes on to compare
it with a man being married or getting a
people from the mosque getting married
uh
you know you know in a legitimately
islamic way getting a paper from the
mosque probably with without the
knowledge of his wife that's my
understanding of what's happened now
first and foremost
i don't want to go straight for the
jugular here
because although
miriam webster's dictionary and
cambridge dictionary both of them
defined the term stepping out as being
unfaithful which of course includes
sexual
uh infidelity here it's talking about a
woman who's committed adultery versus a
man who's married another woman
although that could be interpreted like
this
i will not interpret it like that
because there is plausible deniability i
will employ hoss navan on this occasion
and i will actually persuade and
encourage everyone else listening to
this to do so
however because the matter is has some
level of shubha has some level of
ambiguity
i think still
it requires a refutation
and moreover i will say this even if she
did not sister samaya did not intend
what she said
or what what i've just described
this
comparison we find very widespread among
the muslim community a comparison of
a polygyny that is done especially if
it's done
without the first wife's knowledge with
full out adultery which is zinna in the
context of marriage which as we know
both a man and a woman in islam if they
commit such an act
both a man or a woman this is considered
one of the worst
worst sins in all of islam
now let me attack the notion here if
someone who is a muslim who claims to be
a muslim
makes such a comparison
and tries to create continuity moral
continuities between the two notions
then they have actually admitted to
themselves that there is there is
something immoral
in polygyny even
something immoral and pollutiony that
doesn't require the first wise
permission and or consent
i will say where is the evidence for
that i will say where is the evidence
for that in islam
where is if one is
if one is predicating yes
their morality on an islamic system i
want to know the evidence where such two
things can be compared in fact to the
contrary
you cannot compare something the prophet
himself salah did
the sahaba did
with something like this and doing so
means has exposed quite frankly would
expose
yeah it would totally expose
the spiritual bankruptcy that
individuals have on this notion it would
expose it and i'll go further than this
will say not only does it expose it
this one mess allah this one mata here
could be a window to your entire islam
what is your evidence for that muhammad
the evidence for that is what allah
that you believe in parts of the book
and reject other parts of the book
now i'm not saying this by the way just
to make it more clear this is uh
applicable to sister samaya because once
again there is plausible deniability but
the notion that two things come like
this can be compared is totally
is totally incorrect
now i want to take a step back and talk
about something quite important
individuals because this has pastoral
implications who are actually going
through polygamy and you know women
particularly who have serious emotions
you know because it's difficult
it is a jihad in itself it is a struggle
especially for the first wife
you know it's very difficult anxiety and
jealousy and anger and frustration
it is not haram for a woman and i make
this very clear it is not haram for a
woman
to
not like polygamy for herself
the prophet muhammad said clearly
that jannah has been surrounded by hated
things dislike things
and allah subhanahu wa he says in the
quran
he says
has been prescribed for you and it is
hated for you and you can hate something
which is good for you
so there's nothing un-islamic
sacrilegious blaspheming about the fact
that a woman doesn't want this for
herself i'm making this candidly clear
it's very important
i mean most women will not want this for
themselves and for good reason that is
within their nature not to like it men
should not blame them for that
let me be clear men should not blame
them for that oh i don't want to no no
that is within her right and her nature
in fact she'll be rewarded
if she continues and is resilient and so
on
however
the problem lies
not in the fact that you hate it for
yourself but that you start to abhor it
or find it repugnant in and of itself
or
as a as a normative practice
practiced by certain muslim
practitioners
let me make this clear by giving in
giving an analogy let me give an analogy
of eating meat okay eating meat
in islam
eating meat is halal
it is not wedjib just like polygamy is
halal it's not worship okay
now somebody can say i don't want to eat
meat because of helpful health reasons
and not eat meat abstain from eating
meat or in fact can hate eating meat
because of what it does to them
physically
or even feel sickened by eating meat
maybe they see some animals walking
around and they feel sick and that the
thought that this animal will be
slaughtered and then i'll consume the
animal therefore every time they eat a
burger or whatever then they actually
feel
physically
sick and so they don't eat meat
they don't like meat for themselves they
find it sickening they don't like it
now it's fine for that muslim say i feel
sick by eating meat and i don't want to
eat meat
but when that muslim turns around and
says look at those people eating meat
you see now what's going on look at
those people eating meat
look at those people eating meat they
are doing something immoral
look how bad they are
how could they eat them
how could they eat meat how could they
do such a thing how cruel they are how
barbaric they are how oppressive they
are now you have moved into more than
just a gray area
because you have now attributed
oppression to something which allah has
allowed
oppression
with something which allah has allowed
and vul
in the arabic language is what if
it's putting something in other than its
rightful placement but then allah says
eat from whatever you like from what we
have allowed and he did not make
so by saying that about those
individuals that eating meat now you've
moved into a major grey area even more
than a gray area now you are
going into the coffer zone i'm not
saying you have committed kuffar or that
you are careful but your your viewing is
a slippery slope because the next step
after that is saying eating meat is
wrong which is the equivalent here by
saying polygamy is wrong it's immoral
it's unjust it's oppressive that
is something which is cool for akbar the
cover that takes somebody out of the
religion of islam
because clearly allah says the opposite
so what i'm saying is that there's a
fine line between analogy one two and
three
having said this
if we go back now and we talk about why
this is so
powerful
the idea that this can be seen as
oppressive to even muslim people men and
women
is actually a powerful proposition is it
because there is a great deal of
academic evidence and first principle
argumentation
from ethics in ethics and morality
on consequentialist grounds or
deontological grounds no it's not
because of any of that the reason why
this is a powerful argument is simply
because men and women especially first
wives have an emotional theological
reaction to the matter and they feel
pain
because they feel pain pain is a very
powerful thing
pain is a very powerful thing and then
when you have pain that pain can then be
transferred onto empathetically to other
women who put themselves in the position
of that particular woman first wife
who went through that pain
and this in psychology is referred to
as
uh emotive
contagiousness or something to affect so
you actually become sorry empathetic
contagiousness empathetic contagiousness
is the term that bloom uses in his book
that empathetic contagiousness that your
pain becomes someone else's pain
and then the general argument is
my pain
how could the how could
such a person allow me to be in pain
pain is oppression basically pain and
impression are two sides of the same
coin that's the brain if i'm in pain
then whoever is causing that pain to me
is oppressing me
of course such an argument is fallacious
it's uh a fallacious argument strictly
from an ethical perspective and
unsubstantiated
however
we'll we'll say something else
just because it's a fallacious argument
from an academic perspective it doesn't
mean this the pain is not real and once
again we have to acknowledge that women
go through a lot of pain jealousy anger
frustration
but just because you're just because
it's true that you have pain
it is true
that you have pain it doesn't mean that
your pain is the truth
meaning here you cannot use your pain to
diagnose
or otherwise
arbitrate what is true and what is false
from a from a moral perspective you have
no
epistemological
or theological right to do so there's no
there's actually no argument there
do you see and i gave the argument
already i spoke to you in the previous
video which you can watch about certain
double standards from a theological
paradigm which certain uh first wives uh
who uphold the act or have shown some
discontent with it
actually employ
but this empathetic contagiousness
although it's not academically robust
it's an emotional argument it's a flat
out emotional argument
which is filled with velocity and
untruth
and is baseless
it is still very powerful
because quite frankly
the statistical abstractions
of the consequentialist arguments for
polygamy on a collective
collectivist level
is something which people can't
empathize with you cannot as bloom said
you cannot empathize with statistical
abstractions
in other words if i tell you
there's for example some
consequentialist arguments or arguments
about consequences if i say to you
uh polygamy solves this problem this
societal problem which one for example
uh it increases the muslims in the in
the world
which for us is an objective sharia
the prophet told us to
do that
for example if someone
polygamy solves another issue which
issue is this
uh single mothers or divorcees who need
to get married and find it difficult on
the marriage market for many years five
years ten years
then they finally find somebody through
polygamy which they would otherwise not
have found
so it solves you have a surplus of women
that now it solves an issue here
it puts more people in psychological if
you put utilitarian basis uh
state of stability
in fact there was there was actually a
study that was conducted on 56
tribes
villages sorry 56 villages i think it is
the only one of its kind
or and this this was a study that was
done in the western academic setting
and in that study they concluded that
there is no harm in polygamy from that
perspective in fact they mention stock
argumentation for some of the advantages
from a collectivist paradigm they say
for example the economic resources are
spread uh it increases um education
obviously because of economic resource
spread than education within their
certain families and so on
so
these arguments i'm putting forward to
you now which are collectivistically
consequential
in nature
are cold
rationalization you can't empathize with
them so even though
on this basis you can make an argument
it's not gonna compete for certain
people who have had emotional
theological reactions with the bitter
pain
of the emotional argument even though
it's a fallacious argument why is the
argument the argument is
uh i feel pain therefore is oppressive
which is false it's a wrong
how do you prove how do you jump from a
to b annie the point is
so that's the first thing so this is
very important
the second thing is to do with this the
point of disclosure because they
mentioned it many times in their video
and i didn't mention it didn't talk
about it
now in the religion of islam
the origin of islam does not encourage
that you always have full disclosure
with your partner
in fact there's a hadith and quite
frankly
i'm saying it reluctantly because some
people may misuse it
some of us
may misuse it especially young people
like me will misuse it yes but the
hadith which says
that lying is not allowed except in
three circumstances and one of the
circumstances is hadith
and to be fair the hadith also says
hadith
that if
her husband
speaks
to his wife or if his wife speaks to her
husband the religion of islam does not
encourage full disclosure when it comes
to marital affairs why because there are
some things which the in romantic
relationships are if
uh explained it can cause some serious
detriment to the marriage and even the
prophet muhammad he did this himself
not that he lied but he kept things
secret and this is in the quran
about
kept
something from some of his wives
he told some of his wife not to tell the
other ones
so this whole discourse which was quite
prominent about no it's you have to be
completely open and honest and so on
this is actually
not substantiated with the text there
are some things in a marital situation
from an islam perspective which should
not be disclosed full disclosure is not
the islamic position clearly not
so this idea as a why doesn't he come
and speak to her person that especially
let me make a prediction for you
if as we're seeing because a lot of
these matters
are actually interconnected there's a
flesh that joins all of this stuff
in the western context for example
we're seeing and i've mentioned this in
previous podcasts we're seeing for
example
men's children be taken away from him
and weaponized at the expense of the
children's well-being their educational
health their physical health their
psychological health and the man
yes and even the extended family of that
man which includes women by the way for
for example the man's mother etc so when
a dispute happens in a marriage or that
the woman will say to the man i threaten
you with the kids
or if you do this you're not going to
see your kids again
so in this situation if the man if you
put him in this position and he gets
married without your knowledge
then you have given him some reasonable
basis to do so quite frankly you have
given him a reasonable you have given
him a reasonable basis to do so because
you're simply saying if you i'm going to
reward your honesty
with destruction
how do you expect quite frankly
a man to respond to such a situation who
let's say is physiologically
inclined towards the politicians option
now if you're a fool quite frankly if
you're a fool then you will say such a
thing because now you're basically
giving him justification not to disclose
certain facts
if you're not a fool and you handle the
matter with maturity then surely the man
may be honest with you may have a full
disclosure and speak to you about all
these matters
this so i predict
so long as
we see runaway fathers which i've
already expressed my disdain for by the
way
runaway fathers and mothers who
weaponize their children continue to
proliferate in our societies and
acquiescence to such figures
we will see more secret marriages or
let's not call them secretary marriages
where the first wife does not know in
society and they are jewish potentially
possible by the way as jurors
prudentially possible as for example a a
woman who does ishtarat before a
marriage according to the hambulim and
some other motherhood which is that she
says before a man gets married if you do
polygamy then the divorce will take
place it's mentioned but
many people mention
at this point i'll give you references
for that so in other words if a woman
says i insist on monogamy and according
to the humbly method they accept it but
other motherhood no
since we're so since we're being jewish
prudentially open say no you shot unless
they bring the hadith
and they say any condition that is not
within the book of allah then it's
already nullified and this is the
majority opinion
okay
so with this
i feel like
what is being encouraged here with the
attack on fat was the attack on uh
religion and so on uh polygyny and so on
an indirect attack i'm not saying
necessarily with the talk sisters but
generally in the muslim sphere
especially in the western world with the
influence of feminism
is a culture of jurisprudential
sensoriousness
a gag culture of jurisprudential
sensoriousness where men
will feel like their their only option
is x y and z and women don't know also
their options that they can do shadow
before the marriage and so on
and i want to say this you know
if we do instead of thinking about the
matter with a solid morality which is
anchored in the quran sunnah and in the
jewish prudential tradition but instead
opt to deal with the matter in a way
which is just based on our desires
then
we would be falling into exactly what
allah subhanahu ta'ala refuted in surat
al-mu'mun
subhan allah says
in chapter 23 verse number 71
that had the truth followed their
desires everything in the universe would
have been completely corrupt
the universe the heavens and the earth
and everything within them would have
been corrupt meaning what meaning that
there is a very delicate and
sophisticated system through which the
universe operates a very delicate a
delicate and sophisticated system call
it the fine tuning cooler wherever you
like
that it's a goldilocks zone of perfect
numbers
everything is if it wasn't like this
then the universe wouldn't be a certain
way
now the same thing applies the phone
that i'm using the microphone i'm using
the screen that you're watching me with
right now
all of that is based on hard
geometry and mathematics it's not based
on your volatile emotions
when you go on a plane it's not based on
your volatile emotions the systems on
the plane the engine on the plane
the the design of the architecture of
the plane is not based on emotions it's
based on hard facts
because your facts actually
are
indifferent to your emotions the facts
are indifferent to your emotions whether
you're
positive or negative
which means now if you decide to let
something as volatile as your own
emotions be the guide your moral guide
in life
then you you'll have a volatile life
you wouldn't allow such a thing to
happen on a plane you wouldn't say let
me based on i am going to ride a plane
that is based on a volatile set of
architectural
uh or arbitrary set of haphazard
architectural uh points of reference
which means what which means that when
you want truth
you opt for the truth which is solid you
don't and organized
moreover i want to make the point of
cognitive dissonance a lot of our
sisters have
its and brothers quite frankly and
brothers as well
they have started to develop
this disdain towards something which
allah has revealed
and by the way we've already mentioned
the ayat which talked about
if i taught me battle kitab and you
really believe in parts of the book
unless i believe in other parts and also
to be fair mention those ayat
which which reference that you can not
like something for yourself but we
there's one other set of ayats which we
haven't mentioned i'll just give you one
example
which is that one
muhammad
that is because they hated what allah
has revealed so allah has destroyed and
nullified all of their deeds
if you if you've become an individual
who went to stage three in the vegan
uh analogy which is now you're starting
to say
that the thing is immoral itself
then you're an individual who now
entertains
oh you hate what allah subhanahu wa
you hate what allah has revealed and
you're you're going to have nullified
actions you are going to have nullified
actions
yes you think this is a laughing matter
in a joking matter this is a serious
matter it's not google culture
yeah this is a serious matter and it
creates even on a psychological level it
creates cognitive dissonance because
cognitive dissonance is a psychological
disorder where you claim to believe in
something
but then actually your actions
show something completely different
so individuals who fall for this kind of
prey full prey to this kind of thing
they are the least psychologically
contented individuals because they
suffer from the deepest and most
entrenched type of cognitive dissonance
which causes an internal struggle within
them which leaves them unsettled and
anxious to say the least
and one more thing i wanted to say about
this whole religion issue
is about framing how this whole thing is
framed now this might sound
unusual to a lot of you
but many of you will know in the public
discourse we hear things the effect of
a man a muslim man has a right to marry
a christian and jewish woman
okay so it's spoken of what the options
of a marital options of a man are spoken
of in terms of rights this is framing
now
i'm saying okay
but a muslim man cannot marry a muslim
woman he's never framed a muslim man
does not have the right to marry a
muslim married sorry a married muslim
woman yeah
but it is never also framed that a
muslim woman has the right to marry
a muslim a married muslim man
so the whole rights responsibilities
rights inhibitions framing
is actually unusual to me it is skewed
it is biased it is wrong another thing
that can be said
is that for example when we talk about
uh
we're talking rights and
responsibilities when we talk about
the issue of policy
some especially non-muslim detractors
it's anti-islamic detractors they frame
the issue as an issue
where men are taking advantage of women
but actually
subsequent wives are also in the framing
here in other words there needs to be an
accomplice
and the accomplice is a subsequent wife
and the subsequent wife is a woman
herself
so why is the issue not seen as a woman
versus woman issue because it is as as
much
a woman versus woman issue as it is a
man versus woman issue there is as many
or even more women involved in the
equation of polygyny
as there are
women in other words more women do
preliginate to other women
in the equation of islamic polygyny then
men do
why because a man can have two wives
three or four in the case where he has
three that's two women doing it to one
or do two have been doing it to two
so how is it an issue of man versus what
the framing itself is disturbing
finally
we have already covered in great length
the issue of resilience and what is
being said to women and you can leave
and this and that
one very common thing that happens in
polygyny is that a woman will
ask or give the man an ultimatum if you
don't if you don't divorce this person
then goodbye
and the prophet saw he said
he clearly said let us
he said a woman should not ask for the
divorce of her sister
and you should not ask your husband give
him the ultimatums haram
and that she will not be given
uh except
what allah has done qatar on another way
that she will not be given from the
dunya except for allah has
has allowed for her so you should try
you cannot manipulate the qatar of allah
subhanahu ta'ala
yeah
try and take someone else's risk away
this is not right
and this can be done directly and it can
be done indirectly
because some women will not say directly
oh you know go in divorce i'll give you
an ultimatum but she'll make the man's
life hell and she will indirectly hint
at the fact that she wants him to to
divorce
the point being here is
these things are not mentioned in the in
the context of polygamy
these things are not mentioned in the
context and the idea of a woman herself
asking for a divorce for no reason
any woman who asked for her husband
a divorce for no reason than is haram
for her the fragrance of heaven these
things are not even mentioned by certain
sisters that are talking about the
rights and responsibilities and issues
like polygamy and that's why it's very
dangerous to come and speak about these
matters without islamic knowledge or
consultation or a fair representation
and that's why this these kinds of
videos are a required counter
to counter these kinds of other videos
and what i will say is when you consider
the mata clearly i will finish with what
i'm about to say
when you consider the matter clearly if
and you have to be honest with yourself
if whether you're a man or a woman but
going back to the vegan example if
you're an individual who has started to
find
disgusting
the fact that other men practice this
act of polygyny in a normative way
yeah
whether they do it in a way which is
just prudentially ideal or not
so long as it is halal and is allowable
through an opinion whether it's musiar
or not because messiah is
allowed in islam
yes it is allowed in islam
so that happened to zama i did this
so she's not doing a 50 50. such a such
a model is also flexible enough to be
allowable in islamic so whether it's
mission
or any type of polygyny which is
acceptable jewish prudentially
if you find yourself looking at such a
thing an action and saying that that is
disgusting in my opinion or i find that
people do that are oppressive then know
that you are skating on thin ice
know that you are playing with your iman
and know that the problem is deeper than
this masala this mess allah this issue
has just highlighted
highlighted the deeper iman problem
crisis that you have
because the real problem is maybe where
you have to look at it the extent to
which you actually believe
that the man called muhammad ibn
abdullah
who came in the seventh century
the man who claimed to be a prophet the
extent to which you believe this is
actually the case that is itself now in
question
because it's not just a matter of iman
or kufar there is a range of different
iman a man goes up and down yakkin is at
the highest
top level
uh certainty that's at the top level
here
yes
but you may be wavering at the 50 mark
you may be at the 55 60
this is where the issue is because
somebody
who believes 100 percent 100 percent
this thing is halal they will not have a
problem with the hukum itself in any way
or the practitioners of it they will
have a problem with it being done to
themselves as we saw the mothers of the
believers and the greatest women of all
time that's fine that you're allowed to
this is what is allowed
this is absolutely no one should be
shamed or blamed for any of that
but this is how it is
so if you realize that you have a hole
in your iman you have to go back to the
drawing board and read the seerah read
the quran do you ask
because when you do things like that
then your iman is raised and this stuff
becomes quite easy to believe to be
honest very easy to believe
that's all i have to say
the prophet muhammad
told us whoever builds a mosque for
allah allah will build for him a similar
house in jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death whenever
someone prays there whenever someone
gives shahada in the masjid whenever
someone learns something in the message
yes
that will be something that you'll have
on your scale